>> for Epste over JD Vance. Didn't you say that? And presumably
your answer >> you're saying it would be harm reduction
to vote for >> So then say it Hutch say that I view Jeffrey
Epste as a better leader than Hassan Piper.
You know you [__] yourself. You know you [__]
yourself. You know you did. >> No you're telling me that
you would vote for somebody who presided over tens of millions
of deaths. Peace goer.
discovering not food shops now from Hassand Hun's community may
be interested to know a familiar face came to recruit her into
the their jealousyguarded liberal coalition. >> Listen,
I just wanted to, you know, stop by and say what's up. Um, but
listen, I'm putting together a team. Like, we got to get a team
going of like [__] strong liberals. All right. >> So,
I do have PCD and I do consume. So, like you're in the network
now and maybe we can have some conversations in the future and
and uh >> I would count as a lower P. Yes. >> Try
to like build up a movement of uh >> I need to I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself around. >> I am I am
a very strong liberal. That's for sure. I do talk about politics
a lot. You know, I'm not >> Well, you agree with me. So,
I you agree with me. So, I assume you're like really smart. So,
>> this picture of Hush is so perfect. This picture of
Hush works. It's so versatile.
It's so versatile, dude. It's so versatile every time. Okay.
H God, it's a good It's a good clip. It's a good clip. Very well
edited. Okay, so that clip generated a lot of buzz on social
media. Lot of buzz.
One Hassan [__] even got a chance to react to it.
Okay, >> let's check it out. >> Putting together
a team like we got to get a team going of like [__]
strong liberals. All right. >> So, I do have PCD and I
do consume. >> So, like you're in the network now and maybe
we can have some conversations in the future and and uh >> I
would count as a lower P. Yes. >> Try to like build up
a movement of uh >> I need to I need to have a little girl
to wrap myself around. >> I am I am a very strong liberal,
that's for sure. I do talk about politics a lot. You know, I'm
not >> Well, you agree with me, so I you agree with me,
so I assume you're like really smart. So, >> it's the Pet
Avengers, dude. I mean, this paired up with the fact that Hood
said he would vote for Jeffrey Epstein as long as Jeffrey Epste
was a Democrat.
What more can you say? Why is it every single one of your haters
soundboard,
>> I mean,
I don't know, man. I don't know.
>> Listen, I'm okay. So, Hassan reacted to it. There was
a lot of hubbhub about it. So Hutch actually quotes the teeny
tiny Tony clip and says, "Let me start the music back up here."
There we go. Hassan had to disavow an actual self-admitted pest
that he regularly collaborated with this last summer. Correct.
If me having two Discord conversations with someone means I own
their edgeord jokes. Hassan for sure owns his friends rampant
sex harassment. Correct.
Uh no. No. That that is the point of the disavow. Hutch. That
is the point of the disavow and moving on and not continue to
to collaborate with that person. Right? Like that's the point.
That is literally the point.
That's the point. That's the point of the disavow. Hutch.
Are we confused about what the point of the disavow is? I'm just
I'm confused. How did How did Hutch go? Here's this guy that
Hassan disavowed and doesn't talk to anymore.
Doesn't Aren't these the same?
Does he Does he not understand?
Does he not understand the primary purpose
of
I don't I don't get it.
Why downplay it if it has nothing to do with you? That's actually
a great question, Ellie B with a fantastic question in these
replies that sort of didn't even get a lot of traction. But is
that not just totally true? Why Why are you saying it's edgelord
jokes? I I don't get it. Why are you Why are you there minimizing
what it is instead of Okay, you can do one of two things, by
the way, cuz I hope when Hutch says that he understands. When
he says Edgelord jokes, he is saying, "I've looked at this and
I I'm fine with it. It's a joke. It's not real."
That's what he's saying there, right?
Does he understand that? That that's literally what it means.
Yeah. No, he doesn't. He doesn't because he comes down here and
he replies to this guy. This guy gives more clips here, right?
And Hutch says, "I do not have any idea what any of this stuff
is." Okay,
then why are you saying it's just Edgeelord jokes? Why are you
minimizing it? Why would you do that when you don't know what's
going on? You don't get to minimize and then go, "Oh, actually,
I have no idea what's going on."
Uh, actually, dude, why are people canceling Harvey Weinstein
over like some some like weird comments he made?
Yeah, guy just likes to take, you know, auditions at 3:00 a.m.
Why are people dis Why are people freaking out about this? Oh,
he like was women. Well, I had no idea about that, brother.
Just be like, I don't You didn't have any idea about it. You
should probably refrain from commenting till you have a good
idea about it, right? Or at least like at least hedge. At least
hedge in some way. I I just don't get it, man.
I don't know that it's fair to frame this as edgeord jokes when
this person has created an entire manifesto in which they admitted
they consumed drawn child, then doubled down on it a month ago
and said they can't help but be attracted what they're attracted
to drawn child.
Okay. Hutch says, "I do not have any idea what this stuff is.
Leave me alone. I don't know. I do not have some kind of ongoing
relationship/ partnership with food shops." Then why why not
just say I don't talk to that person? I talked to them once.
Now, the truth of this is actually sad, okay? It's that Hutch
was spiraling on social media at 3:00 in the morning and he saw
somebody go put in their title Hutch Defense Squad and he decided
he's going to go get up out of bed, walk back to his computer,
and get on this person's stream without knowing anything about
them. Literally, hey, literally, he says it in the clip I bank
somewhere. He says, "Well, you agree with me, so you must be
pretty smart." Okay, the truth of it is I don't think he really
avows anything about this person. He just knows that he wants
to promote anybody who's willing to go and defend him. Okay,
that's that's really almost the start and end of it. All right,
but I still have to point out how weird it is that he's willing
to come out and like defend this person with only that basis
in mind. This person has once put in their title that they're
Hutch Defense Squad. # Hutchdefense Squad, right? That's that's
it. Well, I I don't know what he knows in private if somebody
would have told him that it's like overblown or something. I
have no idea here. Like the truth of it is quite sad that somebody
was defending him. So, he called into this stream at like 3:00
a.m. and wanted to talk to them, recruit them to the Avengers,
okay, the liberal
But Hutch is the other other unfortunate thing here is though
that Hutch sort of doubled down on this whole position of like
yeah I'm perfectly happy to work with who support liberal democracy.
It's like it's like come on man come on man come on man what
are we doing here dog?
you're if you're asking I'm just asking if you think calling
all of this stuff edgelord jokes especially if you're saying
you haven't looked into it is fair given everything in those
two videos. I'm not trying to attack you here. I think the question
is fair. Also, I'd say probably the reason people are curious
is because your public conversations are what you are trying
to create are sorry uh because of your public conversations where
you're trying to create an alliance with this person. If that
alliance is no longer on the table, I think just saying that
would help people move on. If I regularly collaborated with this
person that I dude, I don't know why he's created this standard.
This this standard is like this is this is where you like circumn
building out a standard for yourself around like what gets somebody
else in trouble. There's no basis for it. You just basically
build up a standard. It's like well actually if you've collaborated
with bad people in the past ever, then you're responsible for
them. But if you if you just like are on the same side as you
you say the same things as and you constantly react to or or
consistently react to the content of these people,
then they're not on your side at all. And it's like, well, no,
I don't think that's true,
right? And maybe it's not that you're I I wouldn't say you're
like a collaborator or a partner with this person. I think that's
also a misnomer. It's like, oh, you I think you are closely aligned
with this person
and so you probably want to create separation,
right? That these aren't the people you want to collaborate with.
You don't want to be included with them in conversations, right?
Wouldn't that be more what it is? You have like a coalition,
but they have different tactics than you, different beliefs than
you, and so you want to separate yourself from them in some way.
I think it's not really that you closely work with them consistently.
That's not it. I mean, he's just trying he's just disingenuously
trying to deflect from what people are going after him for. Sure.
Sure. And then Hassan, by the way,
I never want to hear Hutch say dead Palestinian kids again. Uh
Hassan deflects to dead Palestinian kids. I never want to hear
about but but Israel Palestine. I don't want to hear that from
from Hutch. Okay. When instead of talking about stuff or instead
of answering tangibly, he just goes, "Oh, here's Hassan's old
tweets. Let me pull this up. Hassan's old tweets." Foods is just
kind of no bueno. Unban acre
acrial whatever. This is like telling me that your coworker is
a really bad person. I care about food shop I care as much about
food shops habits as I care about your co-workers bad character.
Okay. I Why is he trying to get away from the clip of him saying
I'm putting together a coalition with this person?
Why is he he had two conversations with her, right?
Who chops his hutch's colleague? Well, in in so many ways. Yeah.
I feel like Hutch basically declared them his colleague. Jesus.
Okay. All right. All these replies posting the exact same things
are that organized harassment you claimed are that organized
harassment you claimed didn't exist. Does Sissan or does Assan
not? Okay. He's just consistently deflecting that. Okay. All
right.
Okay. By the way, I think like there's a real issue here.
Hutch will say things like, "Will you admit that Hassan does
this?" It's like, I'm perfectly fine saying what Hassan does.
I'm not saying, by the way, like if Hutch got to pick a candidate,
his perfect candidate or Hassan got to pick his perfect candidate.
I feel like there's a decent chance I'd pick Hutch's perfect
candidate. The issue I have is the stuff he excuses based on
like some exclusion criteria, like the the way he does or makes
decisions. That's what I'm That's what I'm critiquing. That's
what I have a problem with. It's like not even I don't think
Hutch would say well I I like it's just that like that's my primary
goal. No, but it's like you're willing to excuse some stuff on
a personal level
basically
under the pretext of like well I you know
I think electoralism is the most important thing. It's like no
I don't think I don't think you should elect like morally reprehensible
people. This is quite literally what MAGA did. They went, "Well,
we don't care that Roy Moore like was hitting on 14-year-olds.
We don't care about that. We're just it's we we have to vote
for whoever the Republican is. You almost got like an actual
in Congress from the Republican side because they made these
decisions. This is how they made their decisions, right?" And
the solution is if you're going to nominate as the party that
I support, I will not support that
That's the solution. But unfortunately that solution
basically once you generalize it unwinds into well it's actually
okay to on a principled level say you won't vote for a candidate
from the blue party.
So they can't even accept that. Hutch is kind of being smart
here, right? He knows that at a base level, at like a bedrock
level, if he admits that he wouldn't vote for a who has a D next
to their name, then you basically admit that there are reasons
and it is reasonable
to on a principal basis not vote for Democrats. So he doesn't
want to give that up. That's what he's fighting for, right? He
argued for Vance over Hassan today. Well, well, that's
H. Was that not on live and learn? We'll we'll get to the live
and learn stuff as well. Okay, so basically Hutch was uh very
very very very very
active on Twitter through all of this. I'm probably only going
to go through a couple more replies. We'll go through this thread
as well. Okay. Okay. So, uh the evil O account says, "So what
you're saying is Hassan disavowed a pest while you as of right
now continue to align and refuse to disavow self admitted food
shops simply because she's friends with Destiny. Didn't you refuse
to speak to Quimman because he called you a Destiny Orbiter?
So, let's see Hutch's response to this. First of all, I have
literally zero idea about anything you are talking about. Secondly,
if I'm aligned with food shops because we had two Discord conversations
about politics and you don't disavow them, you No, no, no. He's
he's leaving out the most important thing.
You haven't said, "No, I will not talk to this person. No, I
don't want to talk to That's like super It should be super easy."
By the way, I kind of assume that about people until they go
until they start being super weird about walking away from the
right. I just assume most people don't want to talk to. That's
how I usually assume people operate. They're like, "Yeah, I'm
I am going to walk away from that." Actually, that's that's usually
what I assume. How the did Dan lose that fight he had with her,
man? It's almost like Dan got told to step down, to step back.
It's almost like Dan would never have lost that fight ever. By
the way, Dan didn't want to fight that person directly. That's
why Dan leaked the whole manifesto on food shops to everybody
he could cuz he didn't want to fight food shops directly at all.
And he'll he'll pretend that's because he just doesn't want to
be involved talking to that person or about that person, but
it's actually that he got told to not to go after them almost
certainly. Okay.
Uh Hutch is trying to move past him making a team offer to Food
Slops because Food Slops refused and that makes Hutch look bad.
He just knows it's out there so he can't take it back or backpedal
or pretend like it didn't happen. His usual approach as the snake
he is. Very funny. Very funny that she now that I now that I
am thinking back to it. She did say that, right? She was like
actually I do talk about politics but like I don't know. I don't
know if I'm doing anything like that. Didn't she say some like
this? I don't I don't know why. I I don't know why he's doing
this. Anyway, asking me what I have to say for these things is
like asking me what I have to say for your cousin's Facebook
feed. I don't know your cousin and I do not give a [__]
Have fun with all that.
Again, you literally went and talked to this person about building
a liberal coalition with them. Just say you don't want to build
a liberal coalition with them and you're super fine. You just
keep saying I don't give a that's not an answer. Just say, "Oh
yeah, I actually just be honest." I was like really bummed that
people were making fun of me. So, I found somebody who was like
supporting me and I just went and talked to them cuz I was feeling
like I just needed somebody to support me. That's it.
If he said that, I I drop this entirely cuz that's the truth.
But he he must think that truth is more embarrassing than just
refusing to publicly disavow.
It's not. It's actually not. That truth while embarrassing is
less embarrassing, Hutch. So, just tell the truth. Ask me again
if I give one subatomic singular fly flying [__]
Go on. Ask me. Nobody cares if I just don't care. Hey, you you
have like this really weird clip. I don't care. Yeah, but we're
all laughing at like this really weird clip and you're you're
getting mad about it. Could you just say that this is weird or
could you just like comment on it? Ask me if I give a ask me
if I give Bro,
what are you doing?
What are you doing? Okay, I'll ask for a fifth time prayer request
since you don't care. Why do you care? Hassan associated with
best whom he disavowed. But we're not supposed to question why
you're so gung-ho in your in your defense of a self-admitted
proud and adamant friend of destiny. I'll ask for a fifth time
as well. Yeah. Okay. He just keeps dis he just keeps
Uh you're looping. Are you okay? How much viance have you sorted
today? I heard abusing that can cause short-term memory loss.
Does Hutch respond to this?
No. Would you ask me to disavow your cousin? I've disavowed every
I've come in contact with. Can you say the same?
I've disavowed every every I've come into contact with. Okay.
Can you say the same, sir? Can you say the same?
I don't know. It's pretty funny, man. It's pretty funny. Okay.
Jesus.
Have you uh Sorry. Uh oh, you're putting together a team. I wonder
if that has anything to do with Destiny saying on Dan's pod the
60 should be the NAT age of consent national age of consent or
maybe that 14-year-olds are hot. Have you disavowed your cousin's
problematic? I super think this is going off track. I don't care
about Destiny's comments and
this is the fourth time you've brought up your cousin in response
to me. Are we reactivating some suppressed childhood trauma by
complaining about a The point is that it's performative to have
to disavow literally everything that you have even the mildest
association with. It's not the mildest association.
By the way, I think I just Hutch can pick do you want to be associated
or not? Like really all we need is for him to say, "Yeah, I just
don't think the Destiny self is serious and I'm just going to
do politics with him." That's you could just say that.
I think that's declaring a position that you don't want to declare,
but like just declare the position
or or don't. I I I don't I would not personally want to press
Hutch on this cuz I don't think it's important to me. But that's
what people are pressing him on and he could just declare his
right? I think what some people are mad about and I understand
it. I just personally wouldn't press on it cuz I don't think
it's productive for me. But what some people are mad about is
they're like, "Oh, you disavowed this person then you went on
his stream."
That's what some people are mad about, I
Right. Anyway, but I'm friends with food shops. You're friends
with my cousin. And it's frankly disgusting that you still haven't
disowed the problematic tweets from 2013. You son of a [__]
Yeah, it's you haven't even responded to the serious allegations
you murdered chickens for sport as a teen. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So Hutch was having a great old time on Twitter. Okay. And that
was leading into last night live and learn. All right. Replying
to teeny tiny Tony. Hold on. There's a reply to the teeny tiny
Tony post as well.
or notes. Oh, it's a reply under this. Okay. At Hutchinson, are
you okay with hanging out with straight up like food shops or
destiny? Just my take, but liberals should probably distance
themselves from, you know, probably a good idea. Are you okay
with hanging out with Aspen Gold, Putin, and Jeffrey
but I've never been in a call with those people or to their apartment.
Like, by the way,
I again, I'll just say I don't think it's important to press
Hutch on on the Destiny connection, but
this response is incredibly suspicious.
This response is bizarre.
This response is weird, man. Like, like, it's actually disconnected
from any rational thought.
It's just a weird response.
I don't know how else to talk about it, man. I think without
further ado, I'm perfectly fine getting to the uh the live and
learn stuff. Okay.
I think the funniest part of this is no longer Pisco. The funniest
part of Lib and Learn to me now is Soy Pill. I think Soy Pill
is fully understanding of how weird some of the stuff looks.
fully understanding and like actually on the side of some of
the other people and he's like trying to find ways to like cut
things up to take Hutch's side and to take like the side that
they're on. It's very very funny to me to watch.
>> And I think it kind of vindicates like what I've been
saying, what I've been trying to tell people about this part
of the internet that they are destructive, they are arsonists.
Um, what I find particularly agrieving about this is that I think
it leads to really bad outcomes where people get hurt. You know,
we ended a program that is estimated to have saved 91 million
lives from 20 from 2001 to 2021. USAD
>> estimated is estimated to have saved 91 million lives.
We can restart that program again if we elect a Democrat president
and potentially spare 10 to 15 million dead people over the next
10 >> Do you think you're telling me right I'm laying I'm
laying out my reasoning. And so like if I focus on one person,
it's because I think there's value in attacking that viewpoint.
And I think like the people that say, "Why are you so obsessed
with Hassan?" This reminds me of when people say like, "Why are
you so obsessed with Donald Trump?" It's like, "Well, the reason
I'm talking about Hassan so much is because he's literally one
of the top streamers in the world. He's insanely influential."
And I think there needs there needs to be people that are that
are out there actively trying to discredit >> his [clears throat]
idiotic, vapid,
Hutch, can we turn it around on you? Would you would you commit
to voting for Hassan over JD Vance in the general? I already
told you I would Minecraft myself if you made me choose between
>> that. That is How does Hutch get away with just avoiding
hypotheticals every single time? He
No, I didn't see that. Well, I might have seen that Ginger. Yeah,
he does the pretty fly for a white guy everywhere all over California.
So, you get out of answering this hypothetical every single time.
And it's like, bro,
how you gonna call how you gonna call Hassan out for I mean,
Hassan, I think, is basically like cutting out of that hypothetical
in my opinion, right? He's just going like, "Oh, I really don't
think it's worth commenting on, right? He's like he's being disingenuous
with the hypothetical, but then Hutch is consistently like that."
>> No, that's a question.
>> I would literally do that. I'm not even >> No,
no, that's not the question. You said So, it's >> Oh, so
just press him. So you so you're not going to vote for the Democratic
candidate. So you're just helping MAGA then he answered he answered
badly. He answered that oh actually not voting for Hassan, not
voting for a Democratic candidate. You've just opted out. You
are helping MA gain power, right? Why doesn't anybody press him
like that? Press him in the same way you guys press everybody
else. >> It seems like you're saying that you prefer to
vote for Jeffrey Epstein than Hassan [__] by transitive
property of >> Wait, hold on. The the choices are Jeffrey
Epste no vote for Jeffrey Epste Democrat suit and so that's already
given and you're equivocal.
>> Oh that's yeah I mean Pisco is going to say transitive
property that you said you vote for JD Vance over sorry you vote
said you vote for Epstein over JD Vance so obviously you'd vote
for
Epstein over Hassad. Totally true. >> You have a different
position seemingly on Hassan [__] running against
JD Vance. And it seems like based on that the transit of property
therefore Epste is preferable to Hassan [__] as leader
and just logically follows. >> I don't understand how much
more Hassan needs to say for people to realize. >> Can
you respond to what I just said about the comparison to >> Don't
do the debate bro thing. I'm going >> Don't make me answer
a question. I just want to say things. Why won't you just let
me say things, Pisco? Just let me say things. Why do I have to
answer any questions? Just let me say things.
Just let me say things.
Why should I have to answer questions on this on this podcast?
say what I have to say. I don't >> dude. And every single
time Soy Pill's laughing at how like intellectually weak Hutch
is every single time they have these conversations. He's just
always laughing at Hutch and how Hutch like can't defend himself
or the things he says at all. Soy Pill just finds it hilarious.
Okay, that's like like Pisco sort of solidified himself on on
the further left part of the spectrum, but I think I think Soy
Pill by virtue of Hutch's like total inability to defend anything
he says is slowly getting pulled left towards Pisco whether or
not he likes it. Okay, he might not like it, but Hutch is like
pushing Soy Pill further and further left every time he talks.
It's very funny.
Yo, uh, hold on. We had two right away. Uh, and Max, thank you
very much. 25 months, 11 months. Thank you guys so much for the
subs. Renewed subs. >> How many more things Hassan needs
to say before people fully understand that he does not believe
in liberal democracy. He is a point about Epste. I just made
a point about Epstein. I'm not putting off this point. Hutch.
I'm not going to Marxist Leninist. No, you're trying. I just
made a point about
Epste and whatnot. And we're talking about you. You think Hassan
is worse than Jeffrey Epstein. THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU. JEFFREY
EPSTE. THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU. WHAT IS JEFFREY?
Like you could run Hutch through some very very gross hypotheticals
here. Okay, Hutch, if you had to hold like a 10-year-old child
down while Epstein them like every every week just to avoid a
MAGA presidency in 2024, sorry, 2028 rather, you would do that,
right? And he'd be like, "Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely." He's
he's like he's basically said that I don't care about the individual
actions of people at all. It's all politics and it doesn't matter
how terrible a person is. It's like, you understand? You're you're
just signing up for MAGA. You're signing up for the worst human
beings to be your politicians. Actually, it's okay to say if
you put this kind of human being in office, if you put them up
on the ballot, I won't vote for them. I have limits to the kind
of person I will vote for. That's totally reasonable to say.
It's totally reasonable to say, I will walk away. Yes, I will
let you do fascism in this country. If you put a on my side of
the board, I will let fascism
>> Boom. Done. Super easy, right? >> When you said
I over [__] JD Vance, >> tell me what is Jeffrey
Epstein's policy
>> Dude, [laughter] you don't need >> I'll be honest.
Before Hutch came along, I felt like the Hassan side of the board
didn't have a lot of great arguments. Okay.
Before Before Hutch came along, I felt like, you know, the neoliberals
were kind of winning completely. And Hutch is like single-handedly
trying to He is the greatest scop. Okay. I don't know if he's
like Qatar's strongest soldier or something. I don't I don't
really know what's going on here. But yeah, I did lose my voice
there. That is that is a rough one. Luckily, I was going high
anyway, so it didn't really affect anything. But how is that
not the question to ask when the whole government is the whole
government is not do you think the whole
even on the Republican side, you understand most of the people
probably aren't, right? It's like there are some powerful people
who are protecting people who are associated with Jeffrey Epstein.
I don't believe everybody's a that's probably something they're
using to like I know it's Come on, man. Come on, man.
We get the files. I don't Bro, you are so far off base on this.
Okay. I'm just saying
I think it's totally fine. I think you're allowed to say I won't
vote
that's my limit. I won't vote for. But the reason he won't say
that is because that obviously opens up
the precise thing he doesn't want. A conversation on where the
line is morally on the kind of person you would elect.
That's a really tough conversation. Now that that leads you to
biting bullets like I don't care that Gavin Newsome did like
he didn't follow his own co regulations. I don't care that he's
kind of an elitist. I don't care that he's got some scandals.
Right? And then you have to bite bullets along those lines. You
don't want to have that conversation. So what you say is no no
like just tell me what the platform is. Stop. Just stop, man.
Just stop. Just stop, dog. Trump is the same as Jeff.
Yeah, but you don't have to elect a You literally don't have
to elect a
You You understand? You could just say you are you are implicitly
voting. You are implicitly putting in the
right. You are implicitly putting in the
if you pick a for us.
to me the second that happens when I'm saying that I go oh both
of these parties are are just looking to protect
is very weird
right it's super easy
you are just saying I I categorically like refuse to vote for
this kind of person
I have no problem with people saying that
if both of your parties are just going to be MAGA then okay the
the democracy project is over find your find your nearest super
smart billionaire that you want to be a surf to. Okay. Personally,
if I were American, maybe I choose the Mavericks owner. Who's
that guy? Mark Cuban. Okay. Mark Cuban. Uh, yes. I will be a
vassel of you, Mark Cuban, in the in the coming billionaire
in the coming coming billionaire like feudal world order. I will
be a surf to you. You seem like, you know, less slightly less
of a evil than the other billionaires. I will be, you know, we'll
we'll destroy democracy and I will live in your FFT. Okay. Thank
you. Thank you, Mark Cuban.
>> Jeffrey, you don't need to know. Here's what I know
about
>> You don't need voted for him over JD >> Here is
what I know that. >> Here is what I know about Hassan.
He romanticizes, lionizes, and know that. >> Did I just
see a straightaway comment? I I did just see a straight comment.
>> Here is what I know about Hassan. He romanticizes, lionizes,
and idolizes Vladimir Lenin. Do you know how many people millions
of people died in
>> Probably lots of people have dude lots of people like
historical figures. I think Julius Caesar's really cool. I think
Augustus is really cool.
Augustus doesn't believe in liberal democracy. Okay. It's a historical
figure that I think had like some cool thoughts, had reunified
an empire, made huge things happen in the world. They were a
monster in a time where monsters moved. Okay.
Does that affect like my decisions on the ground today? No.
No, not at all.
Me thinking somebody's cool or made good decisions or was a great
political leader at a time where basically, you know, democracy
couldn't have won,
that's not that's not weird. Anyway, I'm going to hit play on
this. >> Don't do the debate bro thing. I'm going to say
what I have to say. I don't know how many more things Hassan
needs to say before people fully understand that he does not
believe in liberal democracy. >> He is a point about Epste.
I just made a point about Epstein. I'm not putting off this point,
Hutch. I'm not going to Marxist Leninist. No, you're trying
about Epste and whatnot. And we're talking about you think Hassan
is worse than Jeffrey Epstein. THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU. >> THAT'S
WHAT IT SHOWS YOU. WHAT IS >> YOU DID WHEN you said I vote
for Epste?
>> Tell me what is Jeffrey Epstein's policy platform. [laughter]
>> Dude, you don't need to know JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S POLICY.
YOU DON'T NEED TO >> Here's what I know about
abortion. You don't need voted for him over JD Vance. >> Here
is what I know that. >> Here is what I know about Hassan.
He romanticizes, lionizes, and idolizes Vladimir Lenin. Do you
know how many people millions of people died?
This is a dodge. This is a dodge. This is a dodge. This is a
dodge. This is
No, this is crime.
>> Okay, so now versus Assan.
>> Can Hutch at least do hit versus correctly? Can we at
least get that one?
Can we Can we at least get that one? >> This is not I'm
not I'm not moving off. >> Why you would vote for Hassan?
Why would you vote for her for harm reduction? Hassan would be
better than JD Vance. That's why you would vote for Epstein over
JD Vance. Wait, that's why you would vote for Epstein over JD
that that's why you would vote for Epstein over JD Vance, right?
Isn't it the case that you would vote?
>> Uh, that is true, Porter Beller. It's probably a slight
copout. Okay. It's probably a slight copout cuz I do think one
Hassan Hassan probably would go all the way to Yeah, I've got
the time stamp for that. Rox Hassan probably would go all the
way to saying that like Stalin was cool too or something, right?
It is historically inaccurate. I would say it's hard to say if
Lennon was the guy who would have been is he just like the innocent
idiot or would he have done a lot of the same things? It is difficult
to say, right? He just he died before he could really do anything
with the with the power he'd amassed he amassed
right over JD Vance. Didn't you say that? And presumably your
answer >> you're saying it would be harm reduction to vote.
>> So So then say it Hutch say that I view Jeffrey Epste
as a better leader than Hassan. No. It's on your own.
You know you [__] yourself. You know you [__]
yourself. You know you did. >> No, you're telling me that
you would vote for somebody who presided over tens of millions
of deaths. Pisco
>> Dude, I
even if Hassan were a Marxist Leninist, it's like
dude, it's all so goofy, man. Hassan is not from all every person
I've listened to who has any amount of clips beyond that one
clip on the D program years and years and years ago, okay, says
Hassan's not a Marxist Leninist. He basically is a revisionist,
a Marxist revisionist,
>> He modeled his politics after Vladimir Lenin and then
you're turning it around on me. >> So then just say then
then say Epstein is preferable to
>> I'm starting to feel embarrassed cuz Jose is here and
it's like we're fighting so let's let's Oh, no. You're fine.
[laughter] I'm still wondering why >> just say >> I'm
still wondering how a corpse would get nominated to be the Democratic
>> It's ghost.
>> Well, I can say it. >> I just have to remind you
guys, okay? I just have to remind you guys, Epste's definitely
dead. [laughter] Epste's definitely dead, guys. Just I want to
remind you, Epste's dead. We're talking about this as if he's
alive, but he's definitely dead. He's 100% dead. What? Don't
listen to anybody who tells you he's not dead. I can say it without
any hesitation. I would vote for Hassan over JD Vance in a heartbeat.
And I have a feeling Jose would too. What? Jose, what do you
say? Hassan versus >> like that's that's rough when when
IRI is the more reasonable person in this situation, right?
Like we're having a we're having a a fight over, you know, somebody
that Democrats might not like or somebody who criticizes Democrats.
and and Hyra is like, "Yeah, I get that Hassan criticizes Democrats,
but like I'd still vote for Hassan." >> Yeah. If somehow
Hassan decided to jump into the Democratic fray and become and
run and win. Yeah, of course.
Of course, I would vote for him as the uh the You're the only
one out here, Hutch. We'd all vote for Hassan. We all think he
would be better than the Trump as
>> I think we have we have very we have we have very different
kind of opinion.
Yeah, they all of these people value like their long-term viability
on the internet, right, as political influencers. So, they they
literally won't say totally things out of spite. That's they
they just value their their long-term viability in the internet.
Okay, that's the difference. Pretty obvious difference. And again,
I'll remind you guys, this isn't me agreeing with Hassan on everything.
This isn't me saying I love Hassan's politics. This isn't anything
like that. This is me essentially going, "Yeah, Hassan over Hassan
over Epstein." I've said this repeatedly. The the example I give
is like, I think Hassan's outside the bottom five worst. Like,
I think, by the way, I I'd go further than this. I'd say Hassan
doesn't seem like an evil person to me, but I can certainly exclude
him from like the bottom five human beings of all time, which
I think is what you're trying to do with the Epstein or the comparisons
or maybe even the Lending comparison, Stalin comparison. Certainly,
right? I can exclude Hassan pretty easily from like the bottom
five people ever.
I think that's pretty obvious, man. I I just don't think that's
that's doesn't seem like a crazy thing to say. I was given this
clip for a little context. Hutch also said, I believe that he
would vote for Ben Shapiro over
>> would vote for Ben Shapiro over Hassan. What? Yeah,
I would. Yeah, not going to lie to you guys. I would. Yeah.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
J Hawk doesn't think shocking your dog makes you bottom five
people all time. I don't think so. No, I truly don't.
And again, the the call out here is not that Hassan is good.
Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Han is bad. The call out here is that
Hassan probably shouldn't make you so
angry that you're willing to allow or excuse any behaviors from
anybody around you on the basis that they criticize him. That's
probably, you know, that's where it starts and ends. About as
far as we go on this one. All right. Wait, Radical Rob asked
me if I think they are lying, but I can't tell how long ago it
was in the You think they are lying? I don't know what your I
don't know what the question's about. Sorry, I'm trying to interact
with the Twitch chat. Okay, you Well, you agree with me anyway.
All right, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
All right, so from there, where do we go? I've got a I've got
Hassan's reaction. I don't know if we're all the way through
yet, though. Do we go like how Marxist Lenist governance like
functions and actually is? >> You're taking the worst possible
outcome of unintentional
policies from Assan and comparing them to intentional fascism
and saying they're about equal and I would off myself
[laughter] that's not really >> like okay soy pill this
is another soy pill didn't step in when Hutch was getting pressed
earlier but he obviously thinks the same thing I do. Well, you've
been pressing people on how not making a choice, voting third
party, not voting, abstaining is helping MAGA, but you are saying
you would kill yourself rather than vote for Hassan if you were
the damn candidate. That's obviously a contradiction. You look
completely
Soy Pill's laying that out right now. He didn't want to, but
Hutch keeps going down this totally line.
So
like Soy feels compelled I guess now to actually say something.
So [laughter] he legitimat he legitimately stands Vladimir Lenon.
He thinks that that's a model for how to like conduct governance.
Do you understand that >> campaign campaign rhetoric? >> Okay.
So why the would I ever asking me to choose between him and Jeffrey
Epste? I guess >> you picked Epstein already. You've already
laid that out. Wait wait hut. Do you think Hassan wants everyone
to have healthcare?
Yes or no? No, no, no. I'm not trying to got you. I'm just saying.
Do you think he wants that? Do you think he actually Okay. Uh
I think [laughter] I think the liberal the liberal fascist brigades
are going to be out looking for soy pill. Okay. Hassan wants
something positive. No. No soy pill. No. Hassan is bad. Okay.
He doesn't want anything positive. He wants all Americans dead.
Okay. Okay. So, like I would pick someone who's trying maybe
in a bad way to get universal healthcare from everyone than Donald
Trump who says I'm going to tax uh cut taxes on billionaires
people. I I don't care if they die and let's go send ICE in and
round all these people up. I don't care if worst case scenario
it could be bad. I'm saying >> hang on a minute. Would
you defend Kim Jong-un because everybody in North Korea has healthcare?
>> You think Assan wants Kim Jong-un healthcare? Is that
what he's like? >> This is like Venezuela. Oh, have you
heard of Venezuela guys? >> Literally said literally this
is what he believes like he believes in a uni party. He would
ban political opposition. Do you understand this?
What do I care if I have healthcare if I >> They ban Nazi
partisan Germany. And honestly, I'm okay with that. >> It's
like asking me to choose between like Stalin and Hitler. I choose
neither. I would I would welcome the warm embrace of oblivion
before I had to choose between >> then I don't think I
can you criticize
for saying >> okay
soy pill is going to ask the maybe Soy pill didn't get it before
cuz it's a very obvious question here right
soy pill's about to press Hutch in a way that he is going to
have to listen he's going to have to off himself again instead
of answering this hypothetical I >> I had to choose between
>> then I don't think you
can you criticize Hassan for saying like look I disagree but
he thinks that Gavin Newsome's policies lead to the same bad
outcomes that Trump presidencies do because eventually you get
a new Trump and I disagree with that. But you're making the same
argument now. I feel like you don't have a leg to stand on. >> I'm
right. Who cares if he's saying something different? >> I
don't care. >> No, he's saying the same thing as you. That's
literally any ground you had to make this argument has evaporated
because of how how I don't know how to say this in a way that
doesn't make me sound because of how bad your brain work. Your
brain don't work so good. Your brain don't work, sir. Your brain
don't work. [laughter] You literally can't think these things
through. He like doesn't have second order thinking at all.
And like I don't know how to think about that other than is it
like an IQ issue?
He completely lacks like consequential thinking. You can't think
one step down the state board.
Like you know how chess players think like I think it's what
is it? If you can see if you can sort of anticipate four to six
moves ahead, you can be a really really good chess player. But
but Hutch can't see one state ahead. Hutch like just sees the
current moves and he can move one move. He can't see past the
the like one state. Six to seven. Six to seven. Okay.
And it's it's just crazy to me. >> Who cares? Okay, I'd
vote. All right, Hold on. Let's Let's Let's >> I'd vote
twice for Sorry, Jose. We We get derailed a lot. >> No,
I think it is 6 to7. I'm No, no, no, no, no, no. He's not. No,
no, no. That guy's not memeing. Hold on. Alpha Kilo is not not
memeing. It literally is 6 to7. I said I six was the number and
I wouldn't be shocked if it was 6 to 7.
No, no, no, no, no. I don't think it is. Hold on. You guys all
think he is. How many
um moves forward can chess grandmasters
see? Oh, wait, hold on. This is not the same thing. I do think
I do think it's like they go through a lot of the the like overall
states six to seven, but people say more. So, never mind. Maybe
it is just the meme. >> Oh, no. You're fine. I'm enjoying
it. I'm enjoying. >> No, now I'm too [__]
I think Hassan's a [__] but I mean it is what it
is. And I and I don't see I don't think he has Riz either. Um
it's just uh because he has a lot of influence, right? And when
you call him out on it, when you're like, "Hey, you have a lot
of influence. You should have not done said XYZ. Maybe Kla Harris
could have won." He then backpedals and he goes, "Well, you know,
I'm just a streamer. I live in California. You know, I'm just
this."
>> Yes, evil Johnny Bravo. I understand that point. But
the thing is
is
what you should be able to do is say, "Okay, but if you put that
in, I'm not voting for him." As in that is a signal to the party
that I you cannot pick somebody with that kind of scandal. I
will not vote for them. I will allow whatever the other party
does. I will not vote for them. I will not vote for them. You're
allowed to do that, right? because that is that is how you s
signal to the party like that there is a personal I want good
people who are politicians which is by the way a very good rule
to have that lack of I want good people as politicians that is
how MAGA got to where it is now so in any case I just I think
it's very obvious that you shouldn't be doing this I think this
is really stupid rhetoric
it goes to a point right I understand that it's blue no matter
who but because like on your position on Israel it's blue no
matter blue on your position on how you know on taxation policy,
right? On minimum wage, it's blue no matter who. But I swear
to God, if your position is is blue no matter who, like stop
stop talking. Stop putting those words into the world because
you are hurting yourself. Okay? The whole reason the reason Dems
can do well in elections, I think personally, is because they
are an offset. They are a different choice. They wouldn't they
wouldn't elect Roy Moore. Okay. Anyway, >> idiot. He doesn't
really double down on the on the influence that he has on the
folks that watch. >> Yeah, but he's not Jeffrey Epstein,
though, right? He's not Jeff. >> Oh, yeah. He's not. No,
I said I I said I would vote for I mean, Jeff Epste's dead, but
I would vote for Hassan if he was the Democratic nominee. >> Okay.
[laughter] Why does this guy have to keep saying Epstein's dead?
He hasn't said Lenin's dead. He hasn't said dead. He hasn't said
any of the other hypothetical people are dead. But just I just
need to remind you guys again that Epstein is in fact dead. Epstein
is dead. Epste's 100% dead. Epstein's definitely dead. Just reminding
you guys. I know we're talking about Hassan and it's all jokes
and haha, [laughter] but in a serious sense, Epstein really is
dead. Okay? And we shouldn't joke about that. We shouldn't joke
about that. >> I just don't think he has the um the spine
that it takes to even reach that level because again, he talks
a lot of on his stream, but if you were to call him out on it,
he always backpedals. Even on Twitter, like when people call
him out on it, he always changes the framing of what is being
discussed when he quote tweets someone and he never properly
addresses what the person that he's quote tweeting.
>> I think that's totally I think that that's totally true
and that's one of the reasons why I get I do get triggered with
my boy Hutch who I love. I love Hutch with all my heart. When
he has the lefties in his replies, like 99% of the time they're
not like responding to anything he's saying. And that triggers
me as someone who wants their question answered. Hutch. Um it
triggers me when people dodge. I think he does that a lot. And
I think that's like my answer. >> Oh god, no. Ah, it's
going to be a Josiah question. Uhoh. Uhoh. I don't want to know
this Josiah question cuz Josiah, as much as he doesn't mean to,
he trolls Hutch super hard from the chat. This might be brutal.
Okay, this could be brutal. $5 super chat. If Hutch can't choose
between Stalin and ask him what FDR should have done in World
War II and ask him why he hates America.
If Hutch can't choose between Stalin and Hitler, that's what
could have done in World War II and ask him why he hates >> FDR
did the right thing because
>> yes, he did because
represented the immediate larger threat and then what >> Dude,
dude, dude, dude, there's no way. Yes, Hudge represented the
immediate larger threat. Yes, dude. I knew Josiah was going to
kill him because Josiah just sits here like kind of
I I'm sorry. I'm sorry. That's like the obvious argument. Yes.
And now he's going to go but look at what happened after. It's
like Yeah, that wasn't good. But obviously the larger threat
you just said it was the right decision.
I'm sorry. Is this like is this political theater that's scripted?
I I feel like I couldn't script out more
like a more excruciating interaction. I couldn't script it out.
I don't know what the is happening. >> And [clears throat]
as soon as the war ended, we ended up in a 50-year cold war with
the Soviets.
>> That was the correct decision. No, that was the correct
decision. >> So, you should vote for Stalin Hassan [__]
and then afterwards we can have the Cold War with >> We
can have the Cold War with Assan [laughter] [__]
>> I see what you're doing. I Yeah, I guess you trapped
me with that one. >> God, I'm just
like He actually doesn't see it. He actually didn't see it when
he said it. He He didn't think, "Oh, well, I shouldn't say it
in this exact way."
Do you see what I'm saying? It's there is no second order thinking.
There's literally no no second order thinking at all. He can't
even That's why, by the way, we've made this criticism a lot.
That's why when he had the conversations with Pisco, he wouldn't
answer hypotheticals because he couldn't understand the consequences
of the hypotheticals, answered yes or no. He couldn't think out
like the he couldn't think down that like stateboard again to
say like well if I answer yes these things change well if I answer
no these things change right he actually can't think that far
ahead
and so it's like
and then we get into like this may actually be abuse okay if
electing if if keeping Biden in office was elder abuse then this
is also some kind of abuse I think and that's not to excuse the
opinions cuz they are fairly egregious, but my god, man. >> Good
job, Z. Good [laughter] job. We did it. What's going on in the
news, folks? I mean, Pam freak freaking out over this finance
here. >> Let me just say something real quick. I am calling
for a total and complete shutdown of
Jeffrey Epstein mentions until we can figure out what the hell
is going on because he's
>> until until some viewer of mine explains to me how to
make these arguments, I think we can't possibly talk through
this anymore, guys. What's cool is after the stream, Pisco goes
into his thinking on the entire combo. Um, I do. Yeah, we'll
see. I think Pisco doesn't want Pisco genuinely feels like he's
friends with Hutch. This is my thinking is he genuinely feels
like he's friends with Hutch and so he wants to protect Hutch.
He doesn't want Hutch to get [__]
right?
Okay. Uh, let's see. Let's see. Pisco says this. Do we skip to
Epstein Hassan? I think this Jose guy, I believe, says, "Oh,
we should have gone with Biden, right?
We should have gone with Biden. We should have actually just
we we should have been riding with Biden even after the debate,"
which is unfortunate.
>> Point one,
>> well, I'm giving the context for the ride with Biden
stuff. It was it was fairly silly, okay, that you should be loyal
to these people no matter what. Um this is the thing that blue
no matter who people don't understand. There is like a there
are discernable traits you find far more often in liberals versus
conservatives and vice versa. Okay. One of them is this like
loyalty thing. The value of loyalty. If you are a person who
places a value on loyalty over anything else like you put loyalty
above your own principles. Those people are consistently conservative
at a base level. That is like a that is one of the strongest
predictors of you being a conservative is you believe loyalty
and uh and standing up for like the people around you is incredibly
important. I'm I'm totally stealing this argument. Stalin. Yes.
So when you try to do that for Democrats, you are going to get
your blown the out
because that is not a consistent predictor of you being a liberal,
of you being left in some way.
You will never ever ever ever ever ever ever
be able to convince people who are more intelligent on a general
basis, more um principled on a general basis, who do not believe
that that submitting to authority is important at a base level
on a consistent basis. You will never convince them to do the
same thing. Your base, the base you have chosen to appeal to
does not believe the same things as Republicans. Okay? You will
not succeed with that strategy. you will fail
You don't you don't appeal to these people through like blind
loyalty pledges. You appeal through incentives. And by the way,
you're smarter. You should be able to appeal to incentives. You
should be able to if you can't appeal to incentives, you basically
try to offend as little as possible so that you don't put those
people off from voting for you. That's that's how you should
move in the world as a Democrat. Okay. is for some people
you're does it not like instantly strike you as horrible horrific
do you understand why just like if someone said this about um
Gaza I would have a very negative reaction to hearing that in
response to what was said about Biden and it's so contrary to
everything that Hutch stands for right
even when it makes the party opportunities worse so people like
how could you come out swinging against Jose like it would be
as like you would never say that if a lefty came on and [clears throat]
started talking about well I just have a line and that line is
I don't care what the results are um if it if it worsens for
Democrats down the line we just need to stick by our our our
um principle on genocide everyone be oh my god how could you
say no this is the a worse version of that >> yeah it's
a far worse version of that
but hold on I think Pisco is still on the blue no matter who
stuff it's obviously there are principles that Piscoll would
allow for where you couldn't vote I just think on the Palestine
issue, you were voting against your own interest when you voted
for Donald Trump. If you refused to vote for Harris, Harris was
the the the only hope you had for Palestinians not being like
by all account by all accounts ethnically cleansed. That was
like the only hope you had. And it wasn't even like a strong
hope. I will give you she didn't do very much about the war crimes
they knew about. Um Biden didn't that like it's not like it was
a strong hope. I'm just telling you, you totally if you went
in the other direction, but there have to be principles where
you could totally
justify not voting for a candidate. And if you don't believe
that, you're just not going to win.
It's going to lead you to doing the kind of rhetoric where you're
just attacking people who would vote for you instead of like
providing them reasons to vote for you.
That's what is going to happen. That's what's going to happen
there. It's just leading you down the wrong path. You think you
could do this bullying thing, you can't. It will not >> Do
you understand?
No, we're not saying this. Holy crap. I I honestly think that
some of you guys have like hearing problems. What the >> Are
you saying that Biden would have been worse than Trump? No.
He's saying that trying to keep Biden in when Biden is like brain
damaged, that is a problem. That is a problem. Just like trying
to vote for Epstein is a
is a problem. It's a problem. >> No one is saying that
Biden would have been worse than Trump. Literally no one
would ever say that. >> How do you look credible to your
audience? By the way, the reason these people have followings
is because they've looked credible previously
>> on this panel. It's it's actually and and that's why
I resent after a while and I resented it when Michael Tracy did
it too. When we just keep repeating things we already know and
we do this like loop on like but Biden would be better than Trump,
but Biden would be better. Like yeah, that's all of that is like
pre-baked. And so when people repeat it, it's like oh my god.
But I I hope you understand why I needed to speak up, right?
And why
I'm gonna be like with my big boy voice on cuz this is something
I view as worse. I categorically disavow anybody referring to
Pisco's voice as a big boy voice. If you do this, you're
Please stop doing this. Hutch, Pisco, anybody. We're not doing
Pisco has a big boy voice. Okay, I'm not going to say that. I'm
not going to allow that. I'm going to continuously call that
out. Please don't make me repeatedly point out how weird it is
to suggest that Pisco has the big boy voice. Okay? It's Please
don't do it. Please don't make me say it. >> Please don't
worry every single time. >> And the anti-genocide, anti
whatever principle, the whatever, whatever. >> What does
that say? It's that Pisco is being serious and he's like trying
to set these people straight. >> He's like the dad. They're
saying Pisco was our dad at that point. I don't want to do that.
I don't want Pis I don't want Hutch to say that. It just looks
weird. Okay, it just looks really, really, really weird when
you say Pisco is your dad. Pisco is not your dad. Okay, please
don't talk like that. Please don't >> for the the Again,
this is all assuming worse electoral results for the action or
in action, right? That's all baked in. So don't you don't have
to say it's the same because at least in the Biden case, you're
it's all the same thing, right? We're assuming the worst electoral
result. Okay,
so I hear that and I'm hostile to it. It's worse than the genocide
uh dead ending principle, right? Where it's like, I don't care
if it has no effect on the genocide. I don't care if it makes
the Democrats worse off. I'm going to still take this action
or an action. This is saying the same thing, but because of loyalty
to Biden. And so, in the context of doing that, right, of course,
I'm going to dispute this just as I would someone who made the
same point, but with respect to Gaza,
of course I would. And everyone would understand if there was
a lefty saying it
why I would do that. And so this brings up the first point with
where Hutch is about to contribute. I want to the reason why
I'm stopping
to lay out and say just to be clear uh to the audience what is
being said. It's XY. The reason I'm laying that out is actually
to emphasize for the audience how bad this is. And Hut doesn't
say let want to let me get it out. Explain that.
I want to get it out to say this is horrible actually. And to
remind people, hey, this is against our principles and doesn't
want to let me get it out. All right. No, I heard I want to get
it out because I want to state it so the audience understands
this is its own form of badness. and the hesitancy and we'll
get to hesitancy in a second. The hesitancy to let me lay it
out in those terms, right? The terms are the following. He said
even if he knew the results down ballot would be worse, he would
still say stick with Biden.
>> The reason why
then you understand the danger of what's being suggested
>> and then maybe the response would be more strong. I
want them to actually let that sink in and emphasize it.
Yes, it was said. I want to say just to be clear, what you're
proposing is the following. And then have him not object because
it is what he said. So that there can be also no question that
that is the position he took. And Hutch doesn't want to let me
get it out. So that is like, dude, what's going on? And what's
the reason? Would we protect if it's to protect him, right? If
it's to protect him from from what from criticism. This guy seems
like a decent lib. A good lib, good guy. Whatever. I don't know
much about his prior content, but he seems he seems like a counalial
person. He can defend himself and you wouldn't give this kind
of protection to someone espousing the anti principle. If there's
some other reason why you wanted to cut me off, oh, cuz I'm I'm
just exhausted to hear it. I've already heard it. So, like, dude,
we're spending more time having the interruption fight as opposed
to just like doing the thing, you know? So, that So, I didn't
get to this part. I'm guessing this comes up after between 48
and 58 minutes or 48 and 56 minutes or something. I didn't get
to this part. It's one of the small sections. I'm [laughter]
like, "Okay, bad." >> I'm sensing there's some hesitancy
to fully extrapolate our principle here. So, you might not have
known why these things are related, but they are related. These
conversations are related. Um, listen to committee. So, I did
not like that jab by Jose also despite what he claims. Oh, we'll
get to AOC. Um, yeah. No, I totally agree this as well. Um, and
also Ocula said last year you said you weren't worried about
Trump told him to because you said he was moving too slowly.
Where do you um less worried less worried? >> That was
fast. I I obviously still think it's a significant threat Trump
holds, but um I think that we we're going to win. I do think
that
>> I would tell you if if if I felt otherwise, but I do
feel white white peeled and enthusiast. >> Before you begin
the analysis, could you check my dono question, please?
>> And I would tell you if I felt
>> I really would. >> I feel bad for Aquilla. Okay,
if you guys don't know who Akula is, he was a huge fan of this
channel for a very long time and he unfortunately
he unfortunately broke back towards uh Destiny on Hassan grounds.
Okay, unfortunately he could not he could not could not conscin
Hassan support in any way, shape or form. Okay. And then he eventually
started watching Pisco and now I feel like he is desperately
hoping that Pisco doesn't go back to the same Asan doesn't do
the same thing. Okay. I think he's desperately praying praying
that the same kind of thing doesn't happen. You couldn't possibly
say that Hassan is like not that important to like like like
you couldn't possibly say that Hassan's maybe not like as bad
as and it's like yeah he probably will
unfortunately Hassan it's like pretty easily just Hassan in that
case.
>> Yeah I did. Thank you. I'm there are a lot of people
like this gummy verse unfortunately and
let me tell you
every time one of these guys does it people send me messages
and I don't blow them up and I'm not even saying this happened
with Aquilla but they always go to like DG and then they try
to talk DG. I'm just like bro are you are you serious?
It's so weird to me. Yeah, I wanted to talk about this. It's
like, dude, if anything comes out about Destiny in the future,
I just need like a
I can't do this on Twitch, can I? I can. I can. I can. I can
just speak very vaguely. Okay. Everything I said about Techone
fans, that applies doubly to like if Destiny does something bad
in the future that makes people question whether or not they
follow him. Um, if you were around and in my community, everything
I said about Tee fans goes like double for you, you will never
escape that cult. If you have a moment of lucidity for like even
a microscond,
opt out immediately. You will go back
when he tells you anything. He could tell you anything. It doesn't
matter what he did. He could tell you anything. You will go back
immediately.
So, so if you have a moment of lucidity, don't take that moment
to go like, "Hey, you guys were right." Don't take that moment
to go like, "Well, should I find somebody else?" Take that moment
when you're unplugged for that millisecond, however long it is,
and opt out. cuz it's the only way you will ever get away from
this.
You You are a lost case. Okay? You're a totally lost case.
Oh, I'm not talking about opting out of the Destiny community.
I'm not talking about that. I'm saying whatever I said about
techn fans, you should follow that advice like much faster. Okay.
Trying to read more the super chats when they're in like this
context right here. Um, make sure I read them all because I realize
I haven't been great about that in the past. It's just tough
when there's like a debate going on. Um, but yeah. Okay. These
are related this conversation cuz it's showing me like a little
hesitancy on this principle. The principal espouse is um this
one about by the way that's not I don't care if you watch me
or not. I don't care if you leave. I perfectly understand how
some people might find my content obnoxious. I don't care if
you watch me. I'm just I think we all can all tell what I'm talking
about. >> Reduction related to >> it's nothing to
do with blocking >> voting for Democrats. Vote blue no
matter who, right? That's that the worst of all possible worlds
or something approaching some of the worst people who could be
in charge right now realistically are people like Trump, right?
And the principle is so strong as Hutch so strong that it obviously
will
um survive even Epstein, right? It will survive even an Epstein
candidacy. That's how strong the principle is. And so when I
hear some of if it's going to survive Epstein, surely it will
survive mere loyalty to Biden as a person because he's just such
a swell guy and he deserves it, right? If it's strong enough
of a principle to defend an Epstein candidacy, surely it should
defeat this loyalty principle. You get me? So when I see this,
I'm like, huh? Something it feels like we're not comfortable
with the extrapolations
of some of these positions.
And as I would with any other person who I respect and I respect
touch, >> I'm going to further get into those uh that hesitancy
>> and it mirrors its head again on the Hassan third party
conversation where all of us agree
um deplorable thing to say, disagree with it. Um, I think it's
also like
frankly a bit deceptive
to the extent that it's um
not what it appears and the outrage about the outrage is also
overblown to the extent that it's about strategy or whatever
to the extent that it's about strategy or it's about uh positioning
one's leverage which I've heard from a lot of these um defenders,
right? The sweepers. You mean you someone say that right? Some
someone put that in the comments. You mean you? There's no basis.
I think I could argue with Pisco that's about leverage pretty
Um Pisco just thinks oh well putting that leverage I'm perfectly
willing to accept that Assad is putting that leverage above like
outcomes for the Democratic candidacy and possibly risking. He's
like willing to it's like a like there's just some efficiency
principle. It's like if I increase the chance uh JD Vance is
voted in by.1%
then I'll take a 20% increase in the chance that Gavin Newsome
is not the candidate for the Democratic party. That's what Assan's
saying there. That's the strategy. That's what he's out because
then the out >> he's basically like once you sufficiently
increase the chance that some bad outcome is avoided, increasing
the chance some other bad outcome happens is like acceptable.
And they're basically saying if you ever increase that that second
bad outcome that Republicans that JD Vance gains power, if you
increase it by 0.001%,
any action you're taking is awful and I will not I will not caution
it.
That's but it but it's just about that basically ratio of how
much you can put off the or how much you can increase the other
bad example to to get some other bad thing. It's like just trade-offs,
right? Raers are doing. It's all part of the plan, >> right?
It's all part of the plan. The outrage itself is part of the
>> strategic goal [snorts] of generating hype and consolidating
that precious precious
use of the power, right? which is still forthcoming for the 2024
election, right? That make sense. So, I'm happy to condemn that
that I think it is a bad statement. Everyone here agrees.
Um I forget the exact context here, but it it gets into another
one of these discussions where all of us on the panel except
for Hutch say, "Yeah, we would vote for this is how good our
principle is. This is how much better we are, how much we hold
to this >> um the strong version of Obl no matter who.
We'll bite the bullets." Yes, if a lefty is on the on the ballot,
we'll vote for them because that's just how bad Trump is. But
then, right,
the question is asked, well, what about Hassan? And this is not
the By the way, can I just ask,
how could you ever vote for or support Bernie Sanders and then
say you wouldn't vote for Hassan? That's like saying you think
Hassan is more committed to socialist or communist ideals than
Bernie Sanders was.
You ever seen any of this guy's past before? That's obviously
not true.
Okay,
no offense to Hassan or Bernie or anybody who would take offense
to any of the things I've said, but it's very clear to me that
Bernie Sanders was far more died in the wool, socialist, Marxist,
Leninist, anything like that than Hassan is. It's pretty crazy
to suggest. No,
not the first time I've asked that question.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I'm saying that Bernie has done
far more to set himself aside as a radical who has who is hiding
his power level than Hassan ever has.
If you want to say somebody's hiding their power level, it's
Bernie Sanders. It's obviously Bernie Sanders. >> Famously,
the question has been asked in other contexts as well. >> So
any support for Bernie Sanders over Hassan is insane. Like if
you say you wouldn't vote for Hassan because actually his true
positions are something way No. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. You
have to pick you have to pick JD Vance over Bernie Sanders too
for sure. >> And the question is not answered. The question
goes I would shoot myself in the head before that. >> By
the way, and then those people have to decide well actually
you know Hassan's just performative. Is he performative or not?
Cuz then you have to argue Hassan is so sincere in that one moment
when he says he's hiding his power level in the D program but
is hiding his he's totally disingenuous at every other time in
his life. Like you have to start turning yourself into knots
to try to make this argument work.
How is that different than Hassan's dodge if you know to the
extent that he's with third party I would have to vote for I
would have to do something else. It's a dodge.
It's a dodge. So on the ground of dodging right on the ground
of dodging by the way the Hutch comment on like Ben Shapiro versus
um Ben Shapiro versus Assad.
I don't actually think that's that disingenuous from Hutch. I
think Ben Shapiro is a different kind of conservative who is
totally out of favor with the party. totally like tanked his
channel trying to stand up for any principle he had was willing
to sell out those principles the moment he could to make money
with his channel terrible human being but I'm like okay at least
you know Ben Shapiro at least kind of aligns with some of Hutch's
principles probably does believe in democracy so long as it supports
Israel
okay
in any case but I I do think I don't think it's like that bad
that statement it's not anywhere near as bad as the um as the
Hassan versus JD Vance thing which should be very clearly Hassan
bar >> Absolutely undeniable. They both dodged.
And if this weren't Hutch, if this were econo boy,
if this were econo boy and he was doing this with a mansion versus
Trump
everyone would understand that. Do you understand that? If this
were econo boy and it was this on some like glucenerezi
some kind of like mansiony candidate, everyone would understand
how much of a dodge it was
100%.
And here's the thing, right? They're like, "Oh, the hypothetical
is so
My brother, my brother Hutch, my guy
he did the Epstein one." Right? Here's a problem with the it's
not realistic
approach.
You granted it for Epstein. So, have you guys heard of the transitive
property? Who knows what the transitive I'll read a definition.
Does anyone have uh tell me if this is so here we go. X equals
2.
>> Hold on. Hold on. We little dude. Thank you for the
gifted sub. I appreciate it. We are still downstream. Yes. Okay.
Y
>> Oh, he's just debating. He's demonstrating. Okay, he's
demonstrating the transitive property. >> What does Y equal
two? Let's put it another way. >> Isn't it better to do
transitive property with A implies B?
Shouldn't you do prop logic for this rather than like math? The
transitive property works for math. You do have transitivity.
We'll call this H.
Uh, actually, we'll start with E.
E
is greater than T. >> Just do A implies B.
I I Dude, I'm gonna this up off the top of my head.
Um, transitive property B if is it like if you know Socrates
is a man. So, sorry, you get Socrates is a man and Plato and
Socrates are the same classification of species. Therefore, Plato
is a man. Transitively,
right? Right. Is that not that would be transitivity, right?
I think I think that's a transitive property. I I'm pretty sure.
>> And there's some mathematical sense of transitivity
which is um I think it's the same technically.
No, I'm not doing No, I'm not doing that. I'm not doing uh Socrates
is man, all men is mortal.
Oh, right. No, that is the classic example, isn't it? Like uh
all men are mortal. Socrates is man, therefore Socrates is mortal.
That is the classic example of transitivity. Thank you. Sorry.
I was I was literally not thinking of that. But you're right
that that is a
that is the classic example of transitivity. Here we have H.
What would we say? Equal to >> No, it's it's Sorry, you're
saying equals. This is an implies. You should do an arrow. A
implies B. B implies C. A implies C is the classic example of
transitivity. Yes, >> he said he would shoot himself, right?
Equal to T. So I'm going to take that as
Therefore,
E greater than H.
Does that make sense? >> Oh, he's using mathematical transitivity.
Okay. Okay. Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure. >> Tell me I'm wrong.
>> I mean, it's trivially true. >> If Epstein is
better than Trump such that you would vote for him >> and
you're indifferent such that you would shoot yourself between
Hassan and
>> No, Hassan is H. Hassan is H, not >> therefore
Epstein is preferable to
Am I wrong?
>> Why didn't Hutch state this?
>> Why indeed? Why indeed? >> All right.
>> The reason why he didn't state this is because he wasn't
comfortable with that answer. But why wouldn't he be comfortable
with that answer?
might actually be preferable to Hassan. You don't have to do
that. And by the way, this is precisely why now I again
that why don't people just fight on the actual grounds. I don't
agree that that Gavin Newsome is somebody you could principally
disagree with or principally refuse to vote for based on the
Trump hypothetical on the other side. But there are people I
would principally refuse to vote for, right?
>> Like I was gonna say Ted Kazinski, but then I don't
even want to answer that. Uh, but like there are people there
are people who are bad enough like any given I probably wouldn't
vote for, right? Like I I could just say if you pick a little
to be your party leader, I wouldn't vote for them. I'm just saying
that immediately. Pick somebody who's not a If I find out you
picked a I'm not going to vote for them. you
>> and that is not a bad thing to do. But they want to
basically the argument is you should be able to outly or outlaw
that way of thinking. You should be able to say categorically
that way of thinking is harmful. But it's not harmful. And you
saying it's harmful is like basically just saying you can't argue,
you know, on the merits for your candidates, which is bad. You
should be able to argue on the merits for your candidates.
Just do the work. Just do the work of arguing for your candidates
on their merits. That's it. What if it's a chill? Yeah. Okay.
[laughter] What do we say here? It's like, yeah, I'd vote for
Epste over Hassan, but I'd vote for Epstein over most politicians.
Okay. Guy guy kept it leisurely. What else am I supposed to say?
I I don't actually believe that, but yes. That would be the cool.
Okay. Yes. >> Either because the answer is untrue
>> or the answer is unpopular.
Because if the answer were true,
presumably he would say it, right? If he felt that way. So which
do we think is the case here? >> Because JD Van JD Vance
is generally held as the MAGA standin. The MAGA successor. So
MAGA will continue under JD Vance is how people think about it.
I actually think it'll be worse than that. I actually think it'll
be way worse, but that's just me. >> And then we had the
whole, well, don't you know Hassan equals Stalin?
Hassan equals Stalin.
and therefore you can substitute Stalin in for Epstein or something.
That doesn't really help you though because it doesn't change
that you didn't answer this question. But even putting that aside
like USA
Stalin
he said he said Lenin and then he got to Stalin eventually. Yes.
>> World War II. >> Wait, wait, wait, but but you
understand he he is invoking the actions of Stalin though. Septibus
orgy. You understand that, right? So he said Lenin but then he
invokes the actions of Stalin. He means Stalin.
So he could say Stalin, but he invokes the actions, sorry, he
could say Lenin, but he invokes the actions of Stalin, >> too,
which I believe he granted
near the end with Josiah, right?
you know, poking the bear, the proverbial bear, but never said
this version of it. Yes, I'm I was actually I would take Hassan
over Epstein,
which by the way guys, that's not like
that's not like a huge compliment to Hassan.
Okay, I would prefer Hassan to Jeffrey Epstein, everyone else
on that panel. >> This is where you start the fight in
a way that's like, you understand? I just win. Like, I'll have
this I'll have this argument all day. Like, I pick Hassan over
him. I pick Hassan over Epstein. Like I I'll have this fight
with you forever. What are Epste's policy positions? Hold on.
Actually, Hutch didn't know Epste's policy positions when he
said Epste greater than Trump or Vance. Right. So, we we have
to assume that he believes based on the c the the content of
Epste's character that his positions his policy positions would
be better than that of Trump or Vance.
Yeah. Um in any case, I just think it's very funny. It's like
I think Pisco just keeps taking fights on this. you look sane
to 99% of people. Now, I will say we we all operate in this sort
of bubble where every single person who has this level of derangement
is in our bubble. And so, we get a totally distorted view of
the world. But anywhere else in the world, anywhere else, anything
outside of this tiny little bubble we're in, you look awesome
to everybody. There's literally not a single person in the world
who looks at this and goes, "Oh, yeah. No, like tech definitely
over Hassan. Definitely like Epstein over
So take this fight every single day of the week. You look stupid.
I saw that one email that said in abundance and thought that
meant Epstein was an abundance slip, [laughter] dude.
My god. Agreed
that H over E
and H over T.
So I ask and I'll ask my brother Hutch, which of these is the
case? Why do you hesitate to say that Epstein
would be preferable to Hassan?
Is it because you feel that Hassan that that statement is untrue
that Hassan would be preferable to Epstein? And if he's preferable
to Epstein, he's preferable to Trump.
Or do you know that it is um
in fact
uh like Sorry, I'm saying saying it backwards. Sorry, I'm going
to say one more time. [gasps] Are you refraining
from
saying that Epstein is preferable to Hutch because you know that
Hassan is preferable to Epstein?
In which case, why not say the thing that's true? Or or is it
in fact the case that you hesitate
because notwithstanding its truth or falsity?
It would be unpopular to say Hassan is preferable to Epstein.
Now I'm seeing some people in the in the chat bite the bullet
and say actually Epstein is in fact preferable to Hassan. I don't
agree with that for a lot of reasons.
Just think internally in the Democratic party. But even just
putting that aside, the just put that aside for a moment. If
that's the case, why didn't Hutch bite the bullet? And then we
have the uninteresting hypothetical. And this
is I love this. I love this. I more of this. Okay.
Hey, you know what the price of admission is for chatting? It's
that if you say something, I'm going to pull it up on stream
and humiliate you for it. Okay. Uninteresting hypothetical. Uh
that's literally we do hypotheticals like this all the time.
You saying uninteresting hypothetical clearly tells me that you
actually agree with Hutch. You you want to support Hutch, but
you know you look like a supporting these statements and so you're
terrified to have this brought up over and over again. So this
all drives us back to the same point which is the point of the
hypothetical. Is it because it's unpopular or untrue? It's because
it's unpopular. He know he doesn't want to say it because it's
unpopular, guys. Is it sounds like Hassan fans, doesn't it? Uninteresting
hypothetical. Who cares? It's so far out. Who cares about these
And you're no better on that ground. If that's your response,
if that's your response, you're no better. This is such an >> I,
by the way, I agree with this point where Hassan did not answer
the hypothetical genuinely.
I think Hassan probably if you really had him alone in a room
were just talking to him if you weren't Hutch and trying to do
something alone in that room or test okay and you just wanted
to have a conversation with the guy if you were like Pisco let's
say
um you want to have a conversation about politics you'd probably
go like realistically man rubber beats the road you're voting
Gavin Newsome over JD Vance right and he goes yeah of course
but I just don't want to say it yeah I just didn't want to I
didn't want to bite that bullet in that hypothetical yeah I didn't
answer genuinely yeah I just lied
yeah I just lied Right.
>> Serious. Right. Exactly.
You guys are Hassan fans. You might as well be. You might as
well be. Why do you even care about this?
Why do you care about Epste? Why are you dying on the hill of
Epste?
>> Missyy's Missy's totally right. Missy Missy is like
putting in quotes there to say like she obviously um she's mocking.
I feel like Pisco doesn't understand she's right there. That's
funny. Then there is no one
I think who will defend this stuff. It's indefensible in terms
of trying to stay consistent on the hypotheticals. No, it's just
a dumb choice. It's just a dumb hypothetical. Our hypotheticals
are not dumb.
I'd say also say it's fair to think that the I've had it broad.
I think it's fair to say oh I've had it as in the woman on there
wasn't being a debate pervert with an axioms grounded hypothetical.
Oh, sure. Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. I I think that's
true.
I just think probably it's a it is a hypothetical that he doesn't
want to answer directly. It's that's true. That's true as well.
Like it doesn't matter if it's an axium grounded hypothetical.
You can choose to answer it however you want. And he chose to
answer it in a way that probably isn't true. Okay. Um your hypothetical
is dumb. Even though wait a second, weren't we talking about
I've seen hypothetical
That's the difference. You want to know the difference? Our hypotheticals
are smart and yours are dumb. >> It's void. Now,
>> the reason you don't want to answer is it crushes the
argument. That's why because it crushes. >> I think Pisco
would agree with me that basically like obviously there are some
principles you could hold for your candidates and you could allow
for bad things to happen to uphold those principles. It's just
on the merits where people have said they're making principled
distinctions, principled like stances against the Dem candidate.
Those have probably been dumb stands. That would be my position.
I think that would be Pisco's position. But like overall saying
I'm not going to vote for that's like the Roy Moore argument.
That's what Democrats have been saying all along. Okay.
That's it's just very obvious that that's true. And it seems
like when Hutch says I would vote for Epstein, he's either admitting
well I mean I think he is admitting just a lack of lack of belief
in that that you could say there's a principled there's a place
principally where somebody's you know moral character could go
where I would not follow even if the person on the other side
was of worse moral character. I actually won't do harm reduction
voting in certain senses because I actually think that now you've
both now you're both such bad people. I don't want either of
you running my country and I I'm as a protest vote against my
own party just saying it.
I'm sorry. And listen, I understand that might lead to, you know,
these people seizing power and destroying the country, but I
think you have I I laid this out beforehand. It's important that
I laid it out beforehand. And I'm just saying I'm just saying
no. That's where I draw the line. Sorry. Nick thinks Epstein
is cool. Queen and two, right? Where's the hate coming from?
One, cuz I think it's like ironic.
And two, I'm not like legitimately putting these people up against
each other. Um, and realistically, are we putting like Epstein?
What does Hutch think Epstein is? That would be a good question
to ask cuz clearly when he says this, he's he's literally loading
in. And we all know he's loading in the part where Epste is and
you're trying to get away from that as well here, even less by
appealing to other people. And I don't have to appeal to other
people. I don't need other people or their opinions to ground
my view of the world. I can just say principally I think it's
okay if you say if you pick a in your nomination process I won't
vote for that do you disagree even less do you disagree with
that concept I don't care if it's aliens running on the other
side that are going to nuke the planet earth I'm not going to
vote for
I'm not going to do it now you can say once you get into the
booth do you actually go vote for the well maybe if it's like
actually required to keep the earth running right
>> And I'll [snorts] I'll lay it out right again one more
time for the people in the back. If Epstein greater than Trump
and if indifferent between Trump and
then Epstein prefer >> sorry I'm telling you no Stalin
is I'm saying I'm fine with you saying I refuse to vote for a
pick anybody but a want to vote for them.
I think there's there are some things that you could say are
principally good stances to take.
Like if you could pick anybody in humanity and there's a large
portion of people who say if you vote if you pick a I'm not voting
for them.
I think it's okay for them to say that. Now once they get into
the booth and they're actually going to vote I think probably
you do vote for the unfortunately to not destroy the race but
I think it's totally fine for them to say that throughout the
nomination process to try to get that not picked.
>> To Hassan. >> Oh, my point is that it's unfair
that we roast Hutch but not Nick. Nick is doing like a comedy
bit, right? You understand? Nick is not advocating you vote for
somebody. He's not saying somebody's better than another person.
He's doing like a comedy bit.
You understand that? And also, plenty of people do roast Nick
for that. Yeah. >> Sorry. Are you confused here even less?
Are you confused? Do you think that Hutch is doing a comedy bit
right now? Do you think he's doing like a comedy bit? Do you
think this is like his
Also, I think Nick basically argues that Epstein isn't a at all.
He's in a FEA file. Anyway, that's fine. >> And so,
>> I'm not, by the way, uh, no, Destin, I'm actually not
even really saying I wouldn't vote for a I'm saying that principally
I don't have criticism for people who say, especially before
nomination processes, I will not vote for a if you pick one.
I don't think that principled stance is bad. I don't think the
concept of picking a principled stance
of anything essentially that you wouldn't vote for your candidate
a candidate for your party, right? I don't think that can be
categorically disallowed. Nobody really believes that, but they're
basically arguing that the whole time, right? I think it's goofy
because none of them believe it. I just obviously none of them
believe it.
When everyone else, all the other libs, including myself on the
panel, say, "Yeah, come on. This is too much." What am I led
to believe actually? that this is a rational
preference choice. No,
I have the support of the majority of the panel.
The difference is I'm willing to say it. Yeah, I would prefer
Assan over Trump. Yeah, I prefer Hassan over Jeffrey Epstein.
That's guys, that's not a huge compliment. Okay, that's not a
huge This is This is where we're at. where like who you're you're
hunting Hassan sweepers who are like I think Hassan's probably
outside the top f sorry the bottom five worst human beings in
human history. I think like he's probably outside the bottom
five and people are like oh even though he's a Marxist Leninist
like yeah even if you were a Marxist Leninist probably but also
I don't even think he's a Marxist Leninist so you sound a little
silly to me. You just sound goofy. >> Compliment it all.
pass on. >> Like that's really that should be you should
be just getting laughed out of rooms when you say these things,
right? Like nobody should take P seriously for politics. Nobody
should take Destiny seriously for politics. When they're saying
these things over and over when Destiny goes and says that Pisco
shouldn't comment. I guess you just don't know. Yeah. No, you
should actually opt out entirely. You sound very silly. You sound
like a very goofy silly person who's like very mad at this guy
who wouldn't let you suck him off and now you're taking that
out on him years after the fact. Okay, that's what it sounds
like to me. if you know that we should respond to them as appropriate,
call out their bad takes as appropriate, but the obsession is
something I don't understand. The obsession is something I I
don't understand and and why um as opposed to someone like Piers
Morgan, as opposed to like Joe Rogan. If you don't understand
the obsession at this point, you're probably just not qualified
to have an opinion on anything going on here. I don't think you
should talk. >> If you don't understand why we think Hassan's
worse than maybe you're not qualified to come into politics.
Yeah. No, you're
go away. Actually, go away. You're embarrassing, man. It's so
embarrassing, dog. Look at my LOOK AT MY LIBERALS, DOG. LOOK
AT MY LIBERALS, DOG. What are my liberals doing, dog? Bro, I'll
say even IRI wants nothing. I I've never been more convinced
in this precise moment that IRI is actually intelligent. Okay.
I I usually think he's just a damshell. He just goes instantly.
No, I vote I vote Hassan immediately, obviously. Yeah, I'm not
picking up over Hassan. Yeah, I'm picking Hassan over JD Vance.
It's like, yeah, okay. Damn. Yeah, obviously >> talk about
it. If you can't understand the frustration or the upsetness
of having somebody who is supposed to be on your side, constantly
undercutting all of your candidates refuse to actively endorse
or support Kla Harris in the last election and continues to maintain
the position that either party would have been more or less the
same in power. I just >> Yeah, I don't think he actually
maintains that position for one and it's
It's Epstein and dog. I'm sorry. Yeah, I'M GONNA TAKE THE DOG
shocker over the Holocaust guy. I know that's insane. I know
that's totally insane. I'm gonna take the dog shocker, bro. Give
me the dog shocker. Give me the dog shocker in the world where
he is the most abusive Dumbo owner-like guy, actually. Okay.
>> Don't know why you would even venture like any, >> which
I don't believe. I believe he actually cares about his dog, loves
his dog, takes good care of his dog. But even if he's like the
Dumbo owner who's like totally abusing this dog, so it does tricks
for him on stream and [__] Yeah, I'll still take
him. >> I would have did this at all to offer an opinion.
It just feels like you're like
this would be like me coming out and having like I don't know
why people care so much about AI dubers like I don't [__]
I don't know about it. I don't have a strong opinion on it cuz
I don't know that much about it. I don't know why you would venture
this opinion here. Well, you know, I just Why are you so >> As
opposed to like Dave Smith, you know that we should.
>> Sad. Very sad. Very very very sad.
>> You can say that. >> What is the worst you think
Hassan would do as president? Very easy. abandon the island chain
strategy. Allow China to have unchecked access to the Pacific
Ocean. Easy, instant answer. Easiest answer. Um yeah that that
would that would be like catastrophic for US